I was just like I'm a shower just
cleaned down there one time what is this
pimple okay let me just look it up
Google Google the herpes you might have
HIV or Aids or herpes in Chinese dude I
can't go to doctor my life is over but
that's when I fell into a depression
state so I told myself you know what I
want to kill myself okay herpes bro it's
like one out of five people got herpes
into my feelings stressing out anxiety I
see a guy on a motorcycle
that's how I'm gonna go out bought a
motorcycle that's some suicidal Bro
Ryan help me buy that one you're helping
him with the suicide I assisted him did
you know he had a pimple on his penis I
didn't know that he was going through
any of this at the time why didn't you
as soon as I got on the freeway I was
like holy crap this is fun you know what
I'm gonna live because I love doing this
and I'm gonna keep doing it oh never
fixed your dick I went to the hospital
and the doctor was just like let me see
your dick and he just bro you just gotta
wash your dick make sure to dry it it
was just dirty you almost killed
yourself or a pimple but remember in the
Bible I was like yo this man I
gotta live again